what's going on guys Greg out of here is
John Humphrey we're gonna see a trailer
for one of mighty raccoons upcoming
videos apparently it
Pennywise vs. the Joker teaser trailer
mighty raccoon has done some great
videos he's let us react to a couple
before and he's a real rec room he's a
real raccoon it's amazing Rocket Raccoon
was inspired by this actual raccoon who
started a YouTube channel that's that
was that was some gentle comedy right I
have seen blunt force college this was
very gentle I appreciate
[Music]
[Music]
wiggle your big toe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
interested oh dude that's all original
animation right yes all his work not bad
all his work man
I think we sell like the Iron Man vs
Batman one from this guy appreciate his
hand that's exciting I want to see these
how could the Joker possibly win I mean
the idea of the imagery of the Joker and
Pennywise sharing some screen time and
talking with each other that's the
exciting part is like seeing them
together in terms of versus how the hell
can you hook her possibly Penuel I mean
if a bunch of kids were all he's not
afraid of him at all oh yeah why didn't
I think of that now we're gonna get a
psychological profile on old Joker
certainly if he does like comic book
characters like flashers is flash or
Spider Man included in there it's like
yeah you get to see how the superpowers
go yeah you're just gonna fight yeah
yeah I'm interested to see if he's gonna
do something very different with it I'm
not entirely familiar with all of his
videos I'm not if you're gonna do it
Pennywise versus the Joker the greatest
moments for both of these characters are
dialogue moments yeah yeah so I would
love to see some like interaction
psychological games because yeah the way
Pennywise works is if you're if you fear
him you give in to the fear and then he
can win but Joker doesn't the kind of
guy who could fear him so maybe the
Joker can just shoot him in the original
Stephen King book penny wise also knows
Moy ties he probably has a fighting
chance are limitless yeah I'm sure if he
wanted to he probably could God drop
some kind of fighting stuff I mean
there's got to be a way where penny wise
can get into the Joker
yeah I think this is a chance for some
really cool awesome animation and a lot
more imagery to be infused more than
just them fighting each other yeah the
more interesting family he's already
like developers coming soon but yeah
just that animation alone looks
beautiful and I'd be cool to see some
trippy animation
this is what I'm hoping for oh yeah dude
that was the time now is the time for it
it's Halloween - it's like if he can
make this kind of scary that would also
be awesome if you could actually make
this a scary thing that would be really
cool did some spook UM's going on for
old October oh dude okay well mighty
raccoon I'm looking forward to your
video man I'm looking forward to this
bad boy help me in you can subscribe to
the real rejects but more importantly
subscribe to mighty raccoon click the
notification bell here the more
importantly click mighty raccoons
notification bell you can follow - on
Humphrey on Instagram and Twitter but
more importantly follow mighty raccoon
at Sarah's on Twitter and check out our
patreon become a patron inject today but
more importantly check out mighty
raccoons patriotic hoon on patreon
he definitely is